hallo mein Name ist Luca und meine
lieben Freunde ich schaue mir heute
memes an die meine Community für mich
erstellt hat mit Ansage ich werde
keinmal Lachen habe mir heute neue
Tupperdosen gekauft da steht drauf
spülmaschinenfest weiß jemand wann und
wo das
ihr seid alle am arsch wenn sie genervt
sind du gehst mir so auf den Sack Keks
Wecker ja
wer ist auch immer das zuerst was man
nicht mag und zum Schluss das was man am
liebsten mag immer
immer zuerst dieses Gemüse Zeug und auch
eine ungeschriebene Regel ist der letzte
bisschen muss immer perfekt und lecker
sein
wenn man irgendwas gegessen hat dann am
besten davon was bisschen so ist und
noch ein bisschen Kartoffel kann es sein
dass du dumm bist wer sagt auch immer
noch seinen Eltern Bescheid dass man gut
im Urlaub angekommen ist auch klar und
vom Abflug noch mal schreiben dass man
alle lieb hat wenn du früher bei einem
Freund gechillt hast und er von seinen
Eltern angeschrieben wurde Hilfe boah
ganz ganz unangenehme Situation gewesen
genau die gleiche Situation ist übrigens
die wenn die Mutter von deinem Kollegen
dich nach Hause gefahren hat weil sie
irgendwie die Tochter dann auch noch
irgendwo hinbringen musste und dann
sagst du hinten so mit der Tochter
richtig kritisch Luca heute machen wir
vernünftig auch Luke
ja gut das war das fahrschulvideo wo ich
nur Unfälle gebaut habe
komm ich fahr Stück zurück dass du gehen
kannst aber die Straße komm Berge
Lauf Lady wie ich die Kochanleitung von
der Verpackung ablese die ich gerade in
den Müllheim
immer so immer bei solchen
tiefkühlsachen rausholen zack rein
wegschmeißen und dann überlegen
jeder kennt diese eine Person die schon
Anfang September angefangen hat alles zu
schmücken
ich habe keine einzige Weihnachtsdeko ne
und es ist der 15.5 Sprachen lernen
Babbel einen Krümel vom Handy-Display
schieben wollen ist wie 50 Kontakte
anzurufen 100 Apps zu öffnen und den
Notruf zu wählen das gleiche ist wenn du
dir die Hände wäscht und dann kommst du
ein Tropfen auf dein Handy darauf wie
ich während der Klausur bei meinem Leben
nachdenke weil ich absolut kein Plan
habe was ich aufschreiben soll habe ich
auch immer gemacht dann guckst du so
raus und irgendwann verdammt ich sitze
gerade in der Klausur ich Doppelpunkt
meine Telefonnummer ist 0 1 6 2 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 Angestellter Doppelpunkt ich
wiederhole 0 1 6 2 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 ich
völlig verwirrt und keine Ahnung ob das
jetzt richtig war ja genau oh mein Gott
stimmt
die wiederholen das immer in einer
anderen Reihenfolge wie man selber sich
seine Nummer merkt und dann fällt man
richtig auf den Kopf und weiß gar nicht
mehr so okay musst doch letztens in so
einem Telefonat mit so einer
Computerstimme die letzten vier Ziffern
meiner Telefonnummer wiederholen und
normalerweise merke ich mir die immer so
in so einem Dreier und zweierschritte am
Ende und dann sage ich bitte sofort
[Musik]
ich wenn ich versuche 300 Gramm
abzuwiegen 271 Gramm 289 Gramm 295 Gramm
299 Gramm 1.5
ist genauso wie wenn man irgendwas an
der Theke kauft im Supermarkt jetzt mal
realtalk wie schlaft ihr
boah
also Leute ich habe es euch ja gerade
mal Vollbild eingeblendet Leute die
schlafen wie normal eins sind ganz ganz
viele Menschen ich glaube ich entscheide
mich für drei
ja drei
drei ja schreibt mir mal die Kommentare
als was ihr schlaft wer dachte früher
auch immer dass die Scheiße aus dem
Flugzeug raus
bodenlos genauso wie ein
Flugzeugtoilette dementsprechend wenn du
Kontakt suchst Greif in die Steckdose
ihr seid doch
was macht die citroity in der
Nudelfabrik die Pasta auch
das sind alles News von Instagram die
ich in den letzten Monaten mir immer so
abgespeichert habe und jetzt sehe ich
die teilweise wieder und denk mir nur so
warum habe ich mir diesen Krams
abgespeichert der Moment wenn du etwas
in den Einkaufswagen gelegt hast in der
Hoffnung dass es deine Mutter nicht
bemerkt als ganz unauffällig verhalten
ja immer auch übrigens ein tolles Spiel
was ich entdeckt habe habe ich auch
schon im Podcast gesagt das neue Folge
tatsächlich heute rausgekommen Dick und
Doof auf Spotify ähm ich habe
tatsächlich im Supermarkt Kinder gesehen
die in fremde Einkaufswagen irgendein
Schwachsinn reingelegt haben so dass die
Personen den der Einkaufswagen gehört
dann am Band erst merken hä wer hat denn
diese sieben Packungen Ben und Jerry's
reingeworfen wenn man gechillt in der
Klasse sitzt und plötzlich alle anfangen
etwas zu schreiben
ey das krasse ist
diese ganzen Screenshots von mir in den
memes ich weiß immer ganz genau aus
welchem Video das ist und wo ich das
aufgenommen habe ich bin schon krankes
Opfer ich checke einfach die Frage was
geht nicht ich habe keine Ahnung was Du
von mir willst willst du wissen wie es
mir geht oder was ich mache fragt doch
einfach normal hä ich bin aber ganz
ehrlich ich sage auch mal was geht die
Person aussuchen ob sie sagt mir geht's
gut oder ich mache gerade das und das
Fluggäste wenn sie Eltern mit ihren
Babys einsteigen sehen
es war boah wie braun ich da war ne war
gleich mal mit jetzt
bodenlos ich muss so schnell in die
Sonne Frauen vs Männer
das jetzt sexistisch kannst du nicht
hier behaupten dass Frauen wie ich am
Ende der Klausur noch einen Pfeil hin
zeichne damit der Lehrer Bescheid weiß
dass ich auf der Rückseite geschrieben
habe
immer so ich war auch immer also ich
weiß nicht ob das so ein Ding war aber
ich war auf jeden Fall immer so ein
Kandidat der Weg Klausur noch immer mit
Sternchen gearbeitet hat Sternchen eins
und dann hat man das irgendwo an
klausurbogen Rand geschrieben oder so
ähm was ich schaue jetzt einen Film auch
ich sobald der Film angefangen
wie kommt ihr auf sowas
das ist das ist ja gemein gefährlich was
auch ich denn hier heute für Wörter raus
normale Menschen Duschen mit Duschgel
Luca duscht mit Maschine rein
es ist wirklich gottlos
es ist wirklich einfach gottlos diese
eine Person die immer alles mit filmt ja
komm chill also wenn jetzt ein Haus
brennen würde dann würde ich jetzt auch
nicht meine Kamera ziehen oder irgendwie
anfangen zu bloggen oder so wenn dann
Haus wirklich brennen würde würde ich
mich wahrscheinlich bei den
Feuerwehrleuten entschuldigen dass sie
Arbeit haben weil das Haus brennt weil
ich so nett bin wenn du morgens
aufwachst und siehst dass dein Handy
weh nicht richtig aufgeladen lernt
erstmal Deutsch bevor ihr ihn nie mehr
erstellt okay sehr geehrte kundenkasse 2
wurde so eben geöffnet
die laufen immer alle rüber live von mir
einfach stehen bleiben wenn die meisten
gehen ja darüber obwohl die meisten
stehen dann wahrscheinlich
oder wenn man ganz hinten ja dann könnte
man schnell sein dann lifehack von mir
wenn jemand sich schon zu anderen Kasse
bewegt schon da hingehen obwohl
vielleicht auch nicht so gut weil wenn
die Person was holen will an der Kasse
dann sind danach Leute wenn du jemandem
etwas von deinem Essen anbietest der
aber zu viel nimmt boah das genauso mit
Kaugummis dann ist immer kulant und
bietet an aber wenn ihr dann wirklich
sagen ja doch würde ich gerne nehmen
dann ist man
eigentlich wollte ich nur nett sein es
gibt genau drei Dinge von denen ich mir
immer zu viel mache Hoffnung Gedanken
und Nudeln
letztes meme
wie ich versuche alles zu tragen damit
ich nicht zweimal laufen muss
er ist halt auch wieder wahr ne
lieber auf die Fresse fliegen anstatt
zweimal den blöden Weg laufen zu müssen
allerdings bin ich an der Stelle des
heutigen Video jetzt auch beenden weil
der lieben Freunde wenn euch Luca memes
Part 4000 gibt es ja schon ziemlich
häufig gemacht gefallen hat dann lasst
gerne einen Daumen hoch unter dem Video
hier da abonniert meinen Kanal und
klickt auf die Glocke weitere Videos
nicht zu verpassen wie findet ihr mein
neues Armband
im Internet stand damit hat man mehr
Kraft und kann sich besser bewegen
merke ich jetzt doch nicht so